I am very happy today, because we have
an incredible paper here. Get this,
it helps us transform into virtual
characters and transfer our movements
to them. Wow. But it gets better - we
can even control virtual characters with
different morphology than our bodies. We
can be a tiny little mouse, or a dinosaur.
And wait, it gets even better. From
a three-point input. Not full body.
This is not motion capture where
an entire body suit is used and
we know the movement of every body part.
No sir! What we know here is so much more
challenging - just the movement of the VR
headset and two controllers. Nothing else.
That is really tough. And to me, it sounds
absolutely impossible. So, is it impossible?
Well, almost! Let’s see if this paper
can pull it off. Dear Fellow Scholars,
this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
First, for a training step, it uses motion
capture data to learn which human joints
match the virtual character's joints for training.
Unfortunately, this does not work great, but wait,
don’t despair. Not all is lost. Why is that? Well,
we can now create a reinforcement learning agent
which can lean on this jerky animation, and learn
to control it properly. Here. Whoa! This looks so
much better. Loving it. And note that at this
step, we can throw away all the motion capture
data and we only need the headset and two
controllers. So far so good. So, are we done?
Well, we are not done yet.
Not even close. We also need
a little trickery for dealing with
the head orientation, or otherwise,
we will look like this. And it gets even worse.
Due to the heavy head of the mouse character,
even this can happen. Ouch. But, after this
additional step, look. Mmm! Much better.
Additionally, to add more realism,
we can even decide how we wish to control
the tail of the dinosaur as well. Loving it.
So, are we done? Well, we are still not done yet.
The paper also proposes enriching the training
data with additional information for the AI to
learn, and then throwing this data away. But, come
on, if we don’t do that, what’s the worst that
can happen? Well, this. This can happen. Ouch.
But, putting this all together, hold on to your
papers Fellow Scholars, and look! It finally
works! Now, we have an absolutely miraculous
algorithm that can perform these movements across
different morphologies. With different character
types. It does it in an energy efficient way,
so that we get relatively elegant, smooth
movements, and not those jerky ones. Excellent.
But, wait a second…are you thinking
what I am thinking? Remember,
it has information from the headset and
the controllers. Does that mean that? Yes,
that’s exactly what it means. It has
no lower body information whatsoever,
and yet, it can still reconstruct all these
movements really well. Wow, that is crazy.
And it gets better. Larger and
smaller characters will be moved
around differently. You just
walk around in your own pace,
but for them, depending on their size, more
or maybe fewer tippy taps are required.
And advanced movements are also possible.
Staggering, balancing, you name it. Well,
for smaller, more agile characters, that is. And
we can even try our dancing moves. In this case,
they are perhaps a little inept, but in
a very cute way. And not just movement,
but acting can be done. So good! Loving it.
And yes, it gets even better. If that is at
all possible. I have found three more
mind blowing things about this paper.
One, it has been trained on just one
machine. With one consumer graphics card,
and not even a high-end one. The training
took 24 hours, and this step only has to
be done once, and then, we can use it
in real time for as long as we wish.
Two, so how much training data is required
for this? Get this: only 4 hours. It looks
at 4 hours of footage from a bunch of humans, and
then, it generalizes the movement to new people.
And, three. What you are about to see is the
reason Two Minute Papers exists. Look. This
paper has been seen by less than a 100 people.
Such an amazing work, and I am worried that if we
don’t talk about it here, almost no one will talk
about it. So if you Fellow Scholars would help
me spread the word of these amazing AI / computer
graphics papers, that would be amazing. Thank you.
Now don’t forget, this technique
is still not completely automatic,
I noted earlier that some of the joints of
the human are mapped to the new character,
so you can’t just drop in a completely new
character without some additional work. However,
in return, vastly different morphologies work.
I would estimate that not a great deal of work
has to be done per character, but it still
requires a bit of work an expertise. And I
bet that just one more paper down the line,
and we will be able to do this automatically.
Just imagine a world where we can all become
virtual characters, where we can play together
and the way we move is translated by an
algorithm to feel like we are really any
creature we want. Even if they have a completely
different morphology, big head, small head,
floppy ears, or a tail, anything you can imagine.
And I am absolutely blown away by the fact that
it may not even need to track our lower body for
that. Only the three-point input. Head and hands.
And don’t forget, the differences
between these models are huge. There
are vast variations in weight, 25x difference
between the lightest and heaviest character,
tail joints may or may not exist, and even if
they do, there is a different amount of joints,
same with ear joints, and the amount of
torque they can produce is also subject
to a great deal of variation. And having a
modern algorithm that can translate all of
our motions to these characters is absolutely
incredible. Wow. What a time to be alive!